in this video i'm going to walk you
through the first five hires that you
need to bring on in your company as you
are growing and as a fundamental
framework to think through this you want
to think about especially for the first
five that they are really just helping
you do more and so think of them as
extensions of yourself over time we're
going to transition from that philosophy
to really building a team in departments
but each of the five will more or less
correspond to being an extension of you
and doing the repeated tasks that are
time consuming but do not necessarily
add as much value as some of the more
strategic pieces of each of the roles
all right and so if you don't know why i
am my name is akshmosie on
acquisition.com it's portfolio companies
about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you welcome to mozi
nation i make these videos because a lot
of people broke and i do not want you to
be one of them so let's rock and roll so
the first of these things in terms of
the order and sequence that you're going
to be hiring them in is going to be in
the reverse order of the value that's
being delivered and or where you can get
in the marketplace in terms of dollars
per hour and so the more valuable the
skill the more it will cost and so you
want to replace the skills that cost the
least amount of money for you right
should make sense and so typically one
of the first
two hires and this can happen in any
order is going to be one person who's
going to be more of an administrative
help to you because as you start a
business especially in the beginning
there's lots of administrative work that
needs to be done it must be done but
it's not necessarily the high value work
that's going to move the business
forward but it must be done and so
number one will typically be someone in
that type of role the second hire will
typically be somebody in the customer
success or comes to a support role all
right and you're still likely going to
be heavily involved in the success or
delivery of the product or service that
you have but this person is going to
help take away some of the repeated
tasks that you are doing that are not
necessarily value additive but must be
done all right so this is like handling
returns talking to customers about
repeated tasks uh you know switching out
billing stuff and again you'll see that
there's some crossover between this
administrative role and the uh help with
delivery because in the beginning that's
where a lot of your time is going to
start occurring note that you're still
probably marketing you're still probably
selling because that's what you need to
do at this point in the game the third
piece will likely be the first sales
person all right and that's because and
again this will depend based on how good
you are at sales right so like if sales
is not necessarily your strong suit then
you might take this earlier if it is a
strong suit of yours you're gonna take
it a little bit later because your
dollars per hour in that roll continues
to grow and so i don't want you to take
these as hard and fast rules these are
just general rules of thumb that the
corresponding framework that you need to
be thinking this through is how much
value am i making per dollar and then
how much would it cost me to replace
that dollar per hour so it's like if i
do not generate a lot of dollars power
and it doesn't cost a lot of money then
that will be the first thing now if i'm
generating a lot of money and i can
replace it for a medium amount of money
then it's like well i'm the it's the net
difference right and that's what we're
looking at in terms of how we're
replacing each of these roles and so
right off the bat you're gonna have some
sort of administrative help then you're
gonna have some sort of customer support
help then you're gonna probably hire
some sort of sales role from there now
kind of depends a little bit on the role
you'll probably have someone who starts
assisting you with the promotion or
marketing of your business so this is
oftentimes somebody who's doing setting
or doing prospecting for you or if you
uh generate customers based off content
this is probably somebody who's being a
videographer of some sort or helping you
create the content in some way some of
the more laborious parts that are not as
value additive that would be kind of
that fourth looking higher and again
that can flip with the sales role so
like if for example you're a killer
salesman then you might have somebody
who's prospecting and doing some of the
intro calls for you so that the majority
of your time is spent just closing which
is the higher value task so hopefully
this common theme is working out and
making sense to you because it's like
the number one question i get or one of
among the top questions i get is like
what order should i hire people in when
i'm starting my business the next one is
and again all of these roles can be some
of these things can be fractional right
in the beginning so you'll probably have
some sort of fractional bookkeeper which
is really filling the gap for the
finance hole so they're just doing basic
level of accounting for you to get so
you just know how much money you're
making at that time they can help you
take control of your expenses etc over
time that rule will probably come
in-house but much a little bit later so
like before you're at 100 000 a month
you probably don't have a ton uh that's
going on so just having a fraction
bookkeeper is sufficient same thing with
you know somebody's helping you with
your taxes somebody who's helping you
with legal stuff like you'll have a
lawyer but it's not going to be in-house
and so as you're moving up this value
ladder in terms of the the value per
hour and the cost per hour that you can
get this the process of entrepreneurship
if you think from a big picture
perspective it's always just buying back
your time so that you can level up the
amount of time you're spending on high
leverage activities now here's a key
point i see this happen all the time
i'll see entrepreneurs replace all of
their time and then they don't do
anything with that added time to add
more value and so in that case your
profit margins will go down because you
are not continuing to add and do the
things that generate the income now as
you progress each of these roles become
more solidified and these people ideally
in a perfect world actually can ascend
up and then have teams underneath of
them the person who was helping you
originally now has a team of people
helping them the administrative person
originally you might have to send them
into a director of operations who's
really pushing each of the tasks and
projects forward they end up being a
mini project manager for you if done
properly right the sales person might
become a sales director or sales manager
who's actually leading and training a
series of sales people now i will tell
you that a lot of times people have the
difficulty of going from an individual
contributor at a high level to a manager
it's one of the hardest transitions in
business and it's commonly messed up by
most people all right and so one of the
things that comes with experience in
entrepreneurship is you recognize the
people who have the talent to do the
thing that is required later so you can
hire those people earlier on now you
can't take you know a cool a billion
dollar company and put them in as your
operator one because they probably you
can probably afford it and two they're
probably not that interested in the
opportunity yet unless you have funding
or some sort of vehicle that you can
acquire that talent earlier and so as a
final concept that i want to introduce
to you is that whenever you are starting
a business you are incurring debt and
this is something that i'm now very very
convinced of and so you were incurring
lots of types of debt you are incurring
life debt you are incurring management
debt you are incurring financial debt
you're encouraging technological debt
right so that a technological debt which
by the way is probably if you had
another next full-time hire it's usually
a tech person who's helping you manage
the crm build out sites and kind of make
all the things that you want to have
happen or know should be happening the
background actually happened in the real
world they're helping manage passwords
onboard new new people in terms of
getting them logins all that kind of
jazz and so in terms of the debt that
you're incurring if you don't have a
good crm that's in place you will incur
that debt and then you'll have to pay it
back with interest later when the
company's bigger if you don't have a
good bookkeeper in place you'll have
your finances will be a mess and as you
scale you'll have to fix and pay back
that debt later if you have not the best
people or the values are not there then
you're encouraging management debt which
means you'll have cultural debt which
means you'll have to pay that back later
and so the idea in terms of moving
quickly in the game of entrepreneurship
is recognizing which debt i want to
incur in what order and so i used to poo
poo the idea of investors and venture
capital and things like that who gave
people money to start because i was like
that's not real entrepreneurship and i
think as i've you know weathered or aged
in the game i don't see it that way
anymore i just see it as just
fundamentally an advantage is that
they're choosing financial debt to incur
fewer other debts incur fewer
operational debt incur less talent debt
management debt crm debt like you might
have to have a bigger crm that's better
for you so that you can scale with
having to switch platforms which is
common but it would cost more money up
front so if you're bootstrapped you
might not be willing or able to do that
but if you have funding or you have
money that you're willing to invest in
the business upfront then sometimes you
can do that and so one of the things
that is difficult with people who grow
bigger companies faster is that they
skip through the earlier stages because
they know how to do it and so it's the
reason that each of the companies that
we've had subsequently have grown bigger
faster stronger than the companies that
preceded them because we are willing to
incur less of the other types of debt
rather than financial debt because we
have the finances and so we can skip
steps in the growth process that would
normally off-rail a quarter's worth of
growth by implementing a new crm or
offload a quarter or set me back another
quarter because i have to fix my
financials or set me back another year
because i have a whole bunch of
management team in place where
inexperienced and i need to get more
been there done that's on the team and
fewer i'll learn as i go and so as we're
thinking through this and you're hiring
your team the two major frameworks that
i'd like you to take away with this is
number one you're hiring in reverse
order of value that you are providing
and cost to the marketplace that you can
use to replace it and so typically you
will one gets customer support two some
sort of administrative role three some
sort of sales or setter role four some
sort of marketing assist five some sort
of fractional bookkeeper and or a sixth
which would be your it person or tech
person that is usually the beginning of
the core team and then a christmas tree
is down so each of them right now have
five people hanging off of them let me
see as this that doesn't freeze there we
go you'll have five people hanging off
of each of these not necessarily 5it
people but hopefully you can understand
it especially on the marketing the sales
and on the delivery those are the teams
that tend to grow as the companies grow
and the you know it and and finance
departments and hr departments which end
up getting built over time there's a
ratio that is a higher ratio as in you
need fewer of them per amount of
customers or employees that you have in
the company and so as you scale that is
framework number one and then framework
number two is be mindful of the type of
debt that you are incurring and make
sure it is the type of debt that you
would prefer to incur if you have the
choice and so if you are new to the
channel welcome to mozi nation i have
nothing to sell you and enjoy the next
video bye